Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Bilal Althann.
Ich bin hier auf der Station als Dienstabendarzt tätig.
Und ich würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sie sind damit einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin damit einverstanden.
Okay. Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen,
möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Martin Meier.
Martin Meier.
Können Sie bitte Vornehmend nachnehmen Buchstabieren?
Ja, kann ich machen.
Also Martin wie M-A-R-T-I-N Martin.
Und Meier M-E-Y-E-R Meier.
Okay, danke schön.
Und wie alt sind Sie, Herr Meier?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
62.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 5.07.1961.
Okay, Herr Meier. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich schätze mal wie gesummt 80 kg.
80 kg?
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,73 m.
Okay. Wann sind Sie vom Beruf, Herr Meier?
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ja, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Also ich bin Tiefbau-Ingenieur.
Tiefbau.
Was machen Sie genau, büroflich?
Ein Tiefbau-Ingenieur verlegt Wasserleitungen, Stromleitungen
und macht Bürgersteige oder so Garageneinfahrten
oder in Planung von Straßen und Ähnlichem.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Erklärung.
Darf ich Ihre Familie fragen?
Ich bin ein Freiheits-Tier.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Einer Sohn und eine Tochter.
Danke schön.
Herr Meier, was für Sie zu uns, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Also, so ungefähr seit, ich würde schätzen, so 2, 3 Monaten
fühle ich mich nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Ich merke, ich bin nicht mehr so belastbar.
Ich konnte früher fast 10, 12 Stunden auf der Baustelle gut verbringen.
Ich merke, ich muss mich immer wieder mal hinsetzen.
Ich kann nicht mehr richtig laufen.
Ich habe Konzentrationsschwierigkeiten
und ich weiß nicht, was mit mir los ist.
Haben Sie ungefähr 12 Stunden gearbeitet?
Manchmal auch länger.
Ja, ich denke auch, gut.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden,
die Sie körperlich bemerkt haben?
Nein, eigentlich alles.
Nur, dass ich vielleicht schlecht Luft bekomme, wenn ich Treppen steige.
Aber wie gesagt, nur, dass ich nicht mehr leistungsfähig bin.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder Engengefühle?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Atemnot in Ruhe oder nur bei Belastung?
Nur, wenn ich mich belaste.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein, Husten habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, mein Gewicht bleibt der jahrende Konstant.
Können Sie sich fibrisch?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht warm gefühlt.
Haben Sie nachts Schweiß?
Nacht Schweiß, was ist das?
Nachts Schwitzen.
Mir wird hin und wieder feucht, um den Hals zu an der Stirn.
Müssen Sie manchmal die Kleidung wechseln?
Nein, so weit nicht.
Haben Sie manchmal Herzsturpen oder Herzrasen?
Nein, damit habe ich nie Probleme gehabt.
Ich möchte jetzt über Ihre Vorerkrankung geschickt werden.
Leider Sie an eine chronische Bekannte erkrankten?
Ist mir nicht bekannt, ne?
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nur Operation habe ich nicht gehabt, nein.
Und gibt es bei Ihrer Familie eine bekannte chronische Erkrankung?
Nein, meine Familie ist mir nicht bekannt.
Leben Ihren Eltern noch?
Nein, meine Eltern leben nicht mehr.
Und voran sind Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater hatte einen Verkehrsunfall, er ist dabei gestorben.
Wie alt war er?
Er war damals, glaube ich, so 45 oder so.
Meine Mutter ist vor zwei, drei Jahren an Herzschwäche gestorben.
Herzschwäche?
Nein, meine Mutter ist vor zwei, drei Jahren in Herzschwäche gestorben.
Wie meinen Sie das?
Nachts können Sie gut schlafen, haben Sie Dutch-Schlafstörung oder Ein-Schlafstörung?
Nein, nachts kann ich eigentlich immer gut schlafen.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Appetit ist gut, ich kann immer gut essen, konnte auch immer gut essen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, Herr Meier, leiden Sie unter Stress?
Oder gibt es ein Problem, das Sie sehr nicht belastet?
Nein, nein, nein.
Vermutlich nehmen Sie kein Medikament, oder?
Nein, da ist eben noch kein Problem.
Aber ich glaube, ich will es nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein?
Nein, Medikamente nehme ich nicht ein.
Bei Bedarf z.B. nehme ich etwas Arzneinkotel.
Nein, keine.
Okay, ja. Rauchen Sie, Herr Meier?
Rauchen? Nein, ich rauche nicht. Ich mag keinen Nikotin.
Okay. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten.
Ich glaube, Sie haben sie nie geraucht.
Bitte noch mal.
Haben Sie nie geraucht oder abwählen?
Nein, ich habe nie geraucht. Das ist schon richtig.
Ja, Herr Meier, nächste Frage ist eine Routinefrage.
Ich muss standardmäßig fragen.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Drogen, nee.
Und ich möchte jetzt wissen, ob Sie irgendwelche Allergie haben.
Allergien.
Ich habe nicht aufgefallen, aber ich habe bisher nie mit Allergien etwas zu tun gehabt.
Oder Unverträglichkeiten gegen irgendwelche Lebensmitteln?
Nein, ich habe bisher nie der Fall gewählt.
Ja, Herr Meier.
Von meiner Seite habe ich alle Fragen gestellt, Herr Meier.
Eigentlich habe ich aktuell zurzeit keinen Verdachtdiagnose.
Aber wir müssen zuerst, ich würde gerne Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen
und dann von Ihnen Blut abnehmen und dann vielleicht ein Blutbild sehen.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Können Sie mir helfen, dann bin ich zu sprechen.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay, haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Schießen Sie mir die Schliste?
Neide hocam, schicken Sie die Sender?
Ich habe nicht das Wort.
Ich habe das Wort.
Was ist mir aufgefallen?
Schwellungen.
Schwellungen?
Ne, also eine Schwellung ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie brüchige Nagel?
Negelbrüche, meine Sie. Nein, meine Nägel sind nicht brüchig.
Haben Sie am heißen Globus gefühlt?
Globus gefühlt, ne, habe ich auch nicht.
Und am Bein geschohlene Beine?
Ne, nicht, dass ich wüsste. Meine Beine sind so wie immer.
Gut gesagt.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Konzentration schwer haben.
Könnten Sie die schweren Beschreibungen haben?
Haben Sie gedechnische Störungen?
Man kann das so umschreiben, ja.
Als Ingenieur muss ich viele Daten im Kopf haben.
Ich merke, dass ich viele vergesse momentan.
Vergesse.
Vielen Dank.
Ihre Stimme ist raug geworden.
Noch mal bitte.
Ihre Stimme ist ihre Stimme raug geworden.
Ob meine Stimme sich verändert hat?
Ne, also an meiner Stimme habe ich jedenfalls nichts.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Familie etwas bemerkt hat.
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Aber ich habe nichts festgestellt.
Danke.
Bitte schön.
Sind Sie bei der Arbeit schweren Beschreibungen ausgesetzt?
Sehr gute Frage.
Ne, ich bin nur der Ingenieur.
Ich arbeite mit den Stoffen nicht.
Wann war der letzte Blutwertebeurteilung?
Das sind einige Jahre her.
Da hatte ich glaube ich eine Lungenentzündung.
Da wollte mein Hausarzt ein Blutbild machen.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Bitte schön.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig für die Vor- und Vor-Sorge-Untersuchungen?
Zum Euro- oder Gastronomusik?
Nein, für meine Schande muss ich sagen, das mache ich nicht.
Wegen der Arbeit habe ich immer sehr wenig Zeit.
Und bisher habe ich es immer versäumt.
Es gibt immer wieder schwindel und übelkeit.
Übelkeit oder Schwindel habe ich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit bemerkt,
dass Ihre Stuhlgang etwas verändert?
Mein Stuhlgang hat sich nicht verändert, nein.
Haben Sie eine kleine Verbrötung?
Wobei bitte eine gute Verbrötung?
Ja, eine kleine Verbrötung.
Lymphknotenverkurs. Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Kommt es bei Bagelett Verlösungen zu blau fläken?
Nein, das mache ich aufgefallen.
Warst du in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ja.
Nein, habe keine Zeit.
Okay.
Eine Kollegin hat gefragt, hat Haarausfall gibt es?
So, ob ich Haarausfall habe?
Nein, das mache ich aufgefallen.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen Hautveränderungen abgefallen?
Hautveränderungen?
Hautveränderungen.
Was meinen Sie mit Hautveränderungen?
Ja, zum Beispiel, jeder Augen oder die Hautgelbveränderungen.
Sie meinen so etwas wie eine Gelbsucht?
Ja.
Nein, hat mir meine Familie nicht gesagt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wenn die Luftnot bei Belastung aufgetreten,
ist die Geschichte noch etwas derselben?
Noch andere?
Nein.
Merke dann nur, ich muss mich hinsetzen
oder ein bisschen ausruhen und dann geht es wieder weiter.
Wie viele Stufen können Sie steigen,
bevor Sie Luftnot haben oder stehen bleiben?
Also, früher bin ich auf der Baustelle bestimmt 7, 8 Stockwerke
ohne zu stoppen hochgelaufen.
Und jetzt schaffe ich gerade mal ein Stockwerk,
da muss ich Pause machen.
Wie viele können Sie zum Schlafen?
Ich habe gesagt.
Bitte?
Wie viele können Sie zum Schlafen?
Ich finde, maximal nur eins.
Okay, danke schön.
Beim Bittem.
Könnten wir als das Geschenke anfangen?
Leute, ihr denkt einfach sehr, sehr kompliziert.
Ihr denkt nicht an der einfachsten Sachen.
Blässehaufen.
Bitte?
Sind Sie blasch geworden?
Blaschen.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Blässehaufen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich blasch bin oder nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich denke, Blässe seh'n Sie.
Blässe.
Ja, Blässe.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich sonst bin.
Herr Mayer,
was meinen Sie genau mit Konzentration, Schütterung?
Hatte ich ja vorhin erwähnt,
ich vergesse viel.
Und ich muss mich eigentlich auf der Baustelle,
auf das Projekt konzentrieren.
Und dann merke ich,
ich bin nicht abgelenkt.
Ich bin dann nicht bei der Sache.
Dann erwische ich mich, dass ich mit den Gedanken woanders bin.
Und das kenne ich von mir so nicht.
Können Sie sagen, z.B. Wer treffelt, woher Tag ist heute?
Heute?
Heute ist Freitag.
Das ist was Einfaches.
Also, demant bin ich noch nicht.
Das kann ich schon sagen.
Heute.
Bitte.
Guten Tag, mein Oberarzt.
Fangwann?
Hallo.
Guten Tag, mein Oberarzt.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe gerade einen ganz komischen Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, na klar.
Es geht um der Patient Martin Meyer,
der 82-jährige Patient.
Wie alt ist er?
Ich habe 62.
62?
62, ja richtig.
Ich habe richtig geschrieben.
62?
Ja, 62.
Der am 15.07.1961 geboren ist.
Und der Patient hat sich bei uns wegen seit 2, 3 Monate
eine Malayze und Fatigue vorgestellt.
Malayze, was bedeutet?
Medaille tut Müdigkeit.
Bestehender, progredienter Leistung, Fähigkeit, Konzentration,
Schwerheit am besten ist.
Okay.
Leistung, Minderung.
Ja, Leistung, Minderung.
Okay.
Sametino, Entschuldigung.
Ja.
Ne, ich höre zu, was für Begriffe da fallen werden, finde ich gut.
Man macht sich Gedanken.
Also ich hätte auch gesagt,
Leistungsknick oder Schwäche insgesamt,
oder Müdigkeit, Leistungsknick, Schwäche,
das sind so die Begriffe, die dann fallen sollten.
So Fatigue würde ich nicht erwähnen.
Fatigue ist ein ganz bestimmter Begriff,
der mit einer Therapie assoziiert ist.
Wenn jemand zum Beispiel bestrahlt worden ist
oder Chemotherapie bekommt,
die entwickeln eine Fatigue.
Aber man kann nicht einem Menschen,
der vielleicht Leistungsknick hat
oder Müdigkeit klagt,
gleich Fatigue erwähnen.
Das ist nicht korrekt, das will ich nicht machen.
Aber Müdzi, zwei Wörter,
bestehender, progredinter.
Im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert diese Symptome
und bestehend momentan gibt es diese Symptome.
Ja, hocam?
Ja, also man könnte sagen,
der Patient stellt sich bei uns vor
mit persistierender, persistierender,
Schwäche, Müdigkeit und Leistungsknick.
Das Ganze hat vor drei Monaten angefangen
und hat in der Intensität zugenommen.
Prokredient, ja, kann man nennen,
aber das ist mehr so ein, ich sage mal,
medizinischer Begriff.
Der Deutsche unterhält sich auch eher
mit deutschen Begriffen, sage ich mal.
Und man sollte auch überwiegend
mit deutschen Begriffen auch das Ganze
versuchen zu beschreiben.
Welcher Begriff, wenn ich Müdzi, ja...
Noch mal bitte.
Ich sage, Intensität zugenommen.
Nicht prokredient.
Ja, man kann ja prokredient progres,
das ist so ein medizinischer Begriff,
das versteht nicht jeder.
Aber man sollte auch sagen,
Zunahme der Intensität, das ist das Gleiche.
Also die Stärke hat dann zugenommen.
Intensiv oder Intensität,
kommt auch das Gleiche hinaus.
Bitte schön.
Bitte.
Der Patient hat sich
bei uns wegen seit zwei, drei Monaten bestehende,
persistierende,
Leistung, Leistung schwächer,
Leistungsminderung
und Konzentrationsprobleme,
Konzentrationsstörung.
Der Patient erzählt,
er könne früher
ungefähr 12 Stunden arbeiten.
Aber gerade nicht mehr.
Aktuell kann man sagen, nicht gerade,
sondern man sagt, aktuell kann er das nicht mehr.
Aktuell könne er das nicht mehr.
Und der Patient beschreibt
Konzentrationsstörung
als Vergessenheit.
Konzentrationsstörung mit Vergesslichkeit.
Mit Vergesslichkeit.
Und der Patient klagte
über auch Belastungsabhängigkeit.
Er könne
nicht mehr als ein Stock
Treppe steigen.
Und die Anfohlerkrankungen
wurden verneint.
Die Fragen nach
Wusten, Blutung
und Übelkeit
erbrechen.
Nach Schweißgewichtabnahme.
Nach Schweißgewichtverlust
wurden verneint.
Anfohlerkrankungen
sind keine
Erkrankungen bekannt.
Familienanalyse gab
Vater
mit fünf
und vierzig
wegen
einem Verkehrsunfall gestorben.
Nicht wegen, sondern an einem Verkehrsunfall gestorben.
An einem Verkehrsunfall gestorben.
Und die Mutter
an Herzschwäche.
Herzschwäche.
Herzinsphyseance.
Als erst müssen wir sagen,
Man kann auch Herzschwäche sagen, aber an Herzinsuffizienzen.
Das ist schon ein üblicher Begriff unter Erzen.
Vegetative Analyse ist unauffällig.
Der Patient nehme keine Medikamente.
Er hat nie geraucht.
Er trinkt ganz selten Alkohol.
Drogen, Konsum wurden verneint.
Er habe keine
bekannte Allergie.
Er hat keine
Das war es.
Verdacht ja nicht.
Nach
analysischen Angaben
gehe ich
von einem Verdacht auf
Anämie aus.
Ja.
Um diese Diagnose
festzustellen,
möchte ich
erst den Patienten
körperlich uns untersuchen
und dann von ihnen Blut abnehmen
und Blutbild sehen.
Was machen Sie zuerst?
Welchen Schritt machen Sie zuerst?
Körperlich untersuchen.
Was machen Sie da?
Körperlich.
Ich würde Ihre Sklera
untersuchen.
Sklera ist
ein Auge.
Sklera ist ein Auge.
Die Haut
unter die Hüfe nehmen.
Und in den körperlichen Untersuchungen.
Was machen Sie da?
Was ganz normal.
Was Sie mit jedem Patienten machen müssen.
Sie
verkutieren und
auskultieren diesen Menschen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, körperlich untersuchen
besteht aus vier Teilen.
Was sind die? Was machen Sie da?
Zuerst
Inspektion
mit Inspektion schaue ich
die Haut
an den Körper.
Die Haut
veränderung.
Zum Beispiel
Thulgo
Exikose
und
dann
mit
Palpation möchte ich
den Bauch untersuchen
und dann
Torax.
Ja, bei der Palpation. Wie gehen Sie davor?
Haben Sie da so eine Systematik?
Systematik, bei der Palpation
habe ich
einen Bauch untersuchen und dann
Torax habe ich
Wertschöne.
Also, auch bei der Wiedergabe
im Arzt-Arztgespräch.
Wenn Sie zum Beispiel dem Oberarzt
oder Ihrem Kollegen erzählen wollen
wo der Patient Beschwerden angibt
oder wo Sie zum Beispiel Schmerzen ausgelöst haben
dann sind das ja lokalisierend.
Sie müssen das Abdomen in Quadranten aufteilen.
Also rechter obere Quadrant,
linker obere Quadrant, rechter untere Quadrant,
linker untere Quadrant.
Dann sagt man noch periumbilikal
und dann sagt man noch epigastisch.
Das sind so Spezialbegriffe, die man eigentlich immer parat haben muss.
Sie palpieren immer in all den einzelnen Quadranten
und um die Nabel herum periumbilikal
und aber auch epigastisch unter dem Rippenbogen
genau in der Mitte, dass Sie dann sagen können
hat der Patient dort Beschwerden ja oder nein.
Das müssen Sie schon machen.
Also, wenn Sie dann etwas vermuten,
nehmen wir mal an, Sie haben den Verdacht
der Mensch hat entweder eine Gastritis
oder ein Ulkusleiden, dann sollten Sie
diese Stelle zuletzt untersuchen.
Warum? Wenn Sie diesen Mann
Schmerz auslösen, dann lässt er nichts mehr zu.
Können wir nicht mehr
andere Regionen beurteilen?
Ja, der hat Schmerzen, der wird dann Abwehrspannung haben
und ihre Untersuchung ist dann nicht mehr so gut.
Deswegen sagt man, weil Verdacht auf irgendwelche
Vorkommnisse diese Stelle immer zuletzt machen.
Ich habe persönlich früher immer,
habe ich immer im rechten Quadranten begonnen.
Nicht rechts vom Patienten,
sondern von mir, also linker obere Quadrant
in Richtung Magel unter dem Rippenbogen.
Dann bin ich mehr so linker unterer Quadrant,
mehr so Sikmarbereich
und dann rechter unterer Quadrant
in Richtung Zirkum
oder Appendix und zum Schluss dann so Richtung
Leber oder rechter oberer Quadrant.
Und ganz zum Schluss das Epigastrien
habe ich immer so gemacht.
Aber jeder kann das natürlich so machen, wie er das für richtig hält.
Aber, was ich damals gelernt hatte,
man darf nicht beim Patient die schlimmste Stelle
als allererstes untersuchen.
Es führt zur Abwehrspannung und dann kann man die Untersuchung
auf der Stelle setzen.
Also Abdome palpieren, Systematik
und dann nehmen Sie Ihren Stethoscope,
hören die Lunge ab, rechts, links,
dann macht sie eine Percussion, ja oder nein
und dementsprechend vervorständigen Sie einfach die Körperliche Untersuchung.
Ja.
Vor der Percussion würde ich
Axilia und Haasbereich untersuchen
und ich habe das natürlich hinsichtlich
der Lymphknoten.
Ja, Lymphknoten, ja, kann man machen, ist gut.
Bitte schön.
Sie haben jetzt das Abdomen palpiert,
Sie haben Lymphknotenstatus untersucht,
Sie haben die Lunge perkutiert
und jetzt hören Sie die Lunge noch ab,
vielleicht auch noch das Abdomen, ob Darmengeräusche da sind, ja
das ist eigentlich alles soweit in Ordnung, Sie haben nichts festgestellt
bei dem Menschen.
Der nächste Schritt, was machen Sie dann mit dem?
Hocam,
Differenzialdiagnos hat er nicht gesagt,
bitte Differenzialdiagnos.
Ja, Anime, was für Differenzialdiagnosen gibt es denn bei Anime?
Differenzialdiagnosen, Anime,
es gibt Anime in anderen Varianten, ja, Sie können dann sagen,
also mangel-animie oder plastische Animie
oder Herzinsuffizienz, wenn der Luft noch nicht hat, ja
und Ähnliches, das kann auch vielleicht ein Infekt sein,
viraler Infekt, zum Beispiel,
so eine atypische Pneumonie,
kann so etwas manchmal auch machen, ja,
das könnte so erwähnen, aber ich würde mich schon eher
in Richtung Anime mal orientieren.
Ein Beispiel, keine bemerkten Luftnoten,
aber Lösseme kann sein, zum Beispiel,
aber Differenzialdiagnos müssen wir
drei andere Krankheiten schreiben,
deswegen.
Ja, kann man ja machen, also eine kardiale Ursache kann sein,
eine pulmonale Ursache kann sein,
das kann auch eine hematologische Ursache sein, ja,
also Leukämien sind sicherlich möglich,
dann hätte der eventuell eine sekundäre Folge mit Anime
oder Ähnliches, aber auch eine Herzinsuffizienz
ist sicherlich nicht 100%ig auszuschließen,
der muss nicht unbedingt Udema haben
oder der muss nicht unbedingt mit aufrechtem Körper
immer schlafen, Herzinsuffizienz,
da muss man sicherlich gucken, wie schwer die Herzinsuffizienz ist, ja,
wenn ein junger Mensch eine Herzinsuffizienz entwickelt,
dann kann es auch bei leichtes der Herzinsuffizienz
schon symptomatisch werben für den.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Noch mal bitte.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Burnout-Zendron,
möglichst denken.
Bei diesen Patienten würde ich kein Burnout-Zendron,
weil dann hätte er nicht diese Konzentrationsstörung,
dann hätte er gesagt, er hat keine Lust mehr.
Er ist übermüdet, er hat das Verlangen,
immer zu schlafen und er möchte am liebsten gar nicht mehr zur Arbeit gehen
und jeder Schritt fällt ihm schwer.
Ja, das sind so Ausdrücke, die man mit Burnout verbinden kann.
Aber der Mensch arbeitet ja sehr gerne, das ist sein Leben, ja,
am Tag 12 Stunden, 14 Stunden,
aber jetzt fällt ihm auf,
dass er seine Arbeit nicht mehr verrichten kann.
Nicht, dass er die Arbeit nicht verrichten will,
sondern er kann sie nicht mehr.
Und dann ist es meiner Meinung nach kein Burnout,
sondern eher irgendein anderes Problem.
Okay, danke.
Bitte schön.
Gut, jetzt gehen wir weiter.
Jetzt haben Sie den Körper nicht untersucht
und dann der nächste Schritt?
Nächster Schritt, ich würde Ihnen ein Blutbild sehen.
Blutabnehmen.
Blutabnehmen, ja.
Nehmen Sie einfach mit einem Butterfly,
mit einer Nadel, oder wie gehen Sie da rein technisch vor?
Mit Nadel, brauche ich einfach.
Und wir können auch,
wir können auch mit Finger,
wenn Sie hier im Krankenhaus arbeiten
oder in der Notaufnahme arbeiten,
dann nehmen Sie vielleicht Blut in der Ellenbäufe,
mit Butterfly oder mit einer Nadel ab,
aber Sie müssen solch einem Patienten immer einen Zugang leben,
eine Braunüle, eine Vigole.
Das dürfen Sie nie vergessen, das muss Ihr erster Schritt sein.
Und wenn Sie eine Braunüle legen oder ein Viggo,
können Sie auch darüber gleich Blut abnehmen.
Und Sie haben ja auch einen Verdacht,
der hat irgendeine...
Welche Begriffe gibt es, Testo-Cham?
Braunüle und Viggo, Welche unterschiedlich?
Es gibt keinen Unterschied,
das ist der selbe Begriff, nur andere Bezeichnungen.
Okay.
Manche haben das als Viggo bezeichnet,
die anderen haben Braunüle bezeichnet,
der Deutsche sagt, der einen Zugang legen.
Im Englischen wird das als Katheter bezeichnet.
Es sind alles dasselbe,
Sie können sagen, ob Sie eine Braunüle legen,
das sind Firmen, die das so bezeichnet haben,
oder ob Sie sagen, ich lege meinen Zugang.
Was passieren kann, ist,
dass der Oberarzt dann sagt oder der Prüfer sagt,
welche Größe nehmen Sie da?
Wenn man jetzt mit der Größe kommt,
da bin ich auch ein bisschen in Schwierigkeiten,
weil ich merke mir nicht die Größe
mit 22 oder 21 oder 19,
sondern ich nehme eher die Farbe,
ich sage dann immer rosa Braunüle
oder grüne Braunüle oder eine weiße oder eine graue.
Das sind so meine Bezeichnungen,
die ich dann so parat habe.
Aber Zahlen habe ich nicht im Kopf,
vielleicht sollte man die für solche Prüfungen lernen.
Bilel hat pädiatrische Rüge
und deswegen diese Farbe alles gut wissen.
Ja, ja klar.
Also, wenn Sie vermuten,
dass dieser Mensch eine Anime hat,
dann müssen Sie vorausschauend schon arbeiten.
Dann legen Sie dem einfach einen großlümigen Zugang,
sagt man, eine dicke Braunüle leben.
Mindestens eine grüne.
Und dann nehmen Sie den Blut ab
und Kreuzblut können Sie schon mal mit abnehmen.
Blutgruppenbestimmung, wenn das bisher nicht bekannt ist.
Und dann warten Sie ab, was das Labor hergibt.
Ja, und wenn Sie jemanden mit einer Anime vermuten,
was müssen Sie bei dem noch machen?
Haben wir eben in der körperlichen Untersuchung vergessen.
Darf ich?
Normaler bitte.
Direktal-digitale Untersuchung.
Sehr gut, direktal-digitale Untersuchung.
Um zu schauen, ob jemand irgendein Terstuhl hat oder nicht.
Manche Menschen denken auch um schwarzer Stuhl,
es ist ein normaler Stuhl.
Wenn man dann fragt, ja, ich habe schwarze Stuhl,
aber ich habe Spinat gegessen oder ich habe Sauerkrad gegessen,
das können Sie doch nicht wissen.
Wichtig ist, dass der Arzt trotzdem seine Aufgabe erfüllt
und nicht in diesem Falle den Patienten glaubt,
sondern direktal-digitale Untersuchung trotzdem.
Bei Kindern machen wir das ja nicht, aber...
Raghaden, ja, das ist mehr ein Ausdruck von Eisenmangel-Anämie,
aber bei anderen Anämien muss es nicht der Fall sein.
Bitte, Sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Okul-Test wird im Stuhl, man kann auch...
Ja, das haben wir schon mal gemacht,
aber mittlerweile, dadurch, dass die Laborkontrollen viel, viel schneller sind,
ist das mehr vernachlässigbar.
Im Krankenhaus wird dieser E-Fopt-Test,
der neuerdings so bezeichnet wird, nicht mehr Hemm-Okul-Test,
sondern E-Fopt-Test, der wird im Krankenhaus sehr selten angewendet.
Im Krankenhäusern, wo eine Endoskopie durchgeführt werden kann,
da macht man eher eine HB-Kontrolle
und dann schickt man die Leute direkt zur Endoskopie.
Man verliert dann nicht viel Zeit.
Ich erinnere mich nicht genau der Begriff,
aber mit Blut kann man Verbreitung,
eine Verbreitung unter dem Mikroskop untersuchen.
Blutverbreitung meine ich.
Was heißt das?
Blutausstrich, ja.
Also Ausstrich wollen Sie machen? Was wollen Sie da sehen?
Ausstrich.
Perferik ja immer.
Was wollen Sie da aber auch im Ausstrich erkennen?
Man kann die Löschenne erkennen.
Ja, aber wollen wir denn nach einer Leukämie gucken?
Das wissen wir ja nicht.
Das kann nur eine Hematologe erkennen.
Sie werden das nicht sehen können.
In der Türkei alle.
Ja, ist das so, dass alle Leukämien erkennen unter dem Mikroskop?
Nein.
Sade siebiteanes.
Also es gibt hier ja den Unterschied,
dass im Labor MTAs, Medizinische Technische Assistenz arbeiten
und die sind ausgebildet, die Mikroskopieren.
Und das, was Sie jetzt gesagt haben,
das fordern Sie im Labor an,
dann sagen Sie, ich möchte ein Differenzialblutbild.
Ja, differenzierter Blutbild.
Ein Differenzialblutbild, das kann man maschinell machen,
also Maschinen machen, dieses Differenzialblutbild,
oder manuelles Blutbild.
Das manuelle Blutbild bedeutet, man macht einen Ausstrich
und der MTA, dieser Medizinische Technische Assistenz,
der guckt sich das unter dem Mikroskopern
und zählt die Zellen tatsächlich.
Und das schreibt er dann im Befund mit rein.
Und wenn die dann irgendwelche Blasten sehen,
oder ähnliches, dann melden sie sich auch sofort
und sagen, hey, ich sehe da 20 Blasten oder 10 Blasten,
die da nicht hingehören.
Das könnte eine Leukämie sein.
Ja.
Dafür ist der Labor Mediziner da,
aber das Ganze muss von einem Hermatologen bestätigt werden.
Sonst ist das nicht gültig.
Also Blut abgenommen, Braunöle gelegt.
So, und im nächsten Schritt kommen die Ergebnisse jetzt rein.
Und jetzt haben wir eine riesen Überraschung.
Der Mann hat ein HB von 4,5.
Aha.
Willer.
Und der hat eine LDH von 2000.
LDH, oder?
LDH, ja.
2000.
2000, ja.
Und 4,5 oder 5,4?
4,5, HB.
Ja.
Und die Leukozücken sind 2,2.
Und die Trombozücken sind nur 90.000.
Und was man noch sieht ist,
MCV ist 115.
Was, 115?
Erdreseten?
MCV.
MCV, Keitsche, ist es?
MCV?
115.
Es geht um eine Panzitopinie.
Ja, Panzitopinie.
Was sieht MCHC?
36.
36?
Oh.
Jetzt müssen wir daraus irgendetwas ablesen können.
Ja.
Was sagt denn die LDH von, ja,
vielleicht noch etwas dazu.
Der hat auch ein Billy von 1,8.
Die Lerubin gesamt von 1,8.
Ja.
Also, 2 Informationen liest man da.
Einmal eine LDH von 2000.
Plus Lerubin von 1,8.
Jetzt fehlt noch der dritte Parameter,
der da immer mit draufgeguckt werden muss.
Ja, ja, kann man das auch noch tun?
Nein.
Habtogmubin.
Ja.
Habtogmubin muss man noch angucken.
Und Habtogmubin ist nicht meistbar, ist 0.
0.
So, was heißt das jetzt?
Dieser Mensch hemolysiert.
Ja, hemolysiert kann er nicht.
Er hat eine hemolytische Anämie.
Aber wo?
Er hat eine.
Er hat, die hemolyse ist nicht sein Problem,
der hat ein anderes Problem.
Und das habe ich eben mit den anderen Werten wiedergegeben.
MTV und MTHC sind deutlich erhöht.
Wofür spricht das?
Eine Megaloblasteranämie.
Hyperkroma-Megaloblasteranämie.
Ja.
Und jetzt kommt wieder der Internist in Frage.
Wie entsteht so etwas?
Was ist die meiste Ursache für eine Megaloblasteranämie?
Rettikolozyten.
Rettikolozyten waren nicht gemessen.
Müssen wir noch nachbestimmen.
Sehr gut.
Was erwarten wir bei so etwas?
Wie hoch sind die Rettikolozyten dann in dem Falle?
Ich weiß nicht.
Niedrig.
Rettikolozyten sind niedrig.
Die sind dabei 6,6.
Normalerweise sind die ja, ich glaube, von 15 bis 45,
so um den Dreh rum.
Aber der hat nur 6.
Ultraschall haben sie gemacht.
Mils, wie viel und Leber.
Ist alles so unauffällig?
Ja, besser Vitamin müssen wir...
Noch mal bitte.
Vitamin B12, sehr gut.
Was noch?
Polycoset.
Polycoset, sehr gut.
Beides, Polycoset und Vitamin B12 müssen kontrolliert werden.
So, und jetzt nehmen Sie Vitamin B12 ab.
Und in ein oder zwei Tagen kommt das Ergebnis und sagt,
Polycoset bei 2, was weiß ich nicht.
Und dann kommt das Ergebnis.
Und Vitamin B12, so bei 20.
Und damit haben Sie den Nachweis,
dieser Mensch hat einfach ein Vitaminmangel.
Warum, Mojam?
Keine Beschwerden?
Er hat keine Beschwerden, aber was ist die Ursache für Vitamin B12-Mangel?
Alkohol.
Malabsorption.
Ja, ja, was braucht man denn für Vitamin B12?
Intrinsic Factor.
Noch mal bitte.
Intrinsic Factor, sehr gut.
Und wo wird dieser Intrinsic Factor gebildet?
Magenschleimart.
Und ohne Intrinsic Factor kann dieser Mensch kein Vitamin-Bezürf aufnehmen.
Und auf Dauer entsteht ein Mangel.
Ursache.
Ursache hat damit nichts zu tun.
Aber wenn Vitamin-Bezürfen nicht da ist,
ist auch der Verbrauch von Fulsäure gesteigert.
Und dann entsteht sekundär auch ein Fulsäuremangel.
Ja, Sekunde.
So, jetzt haben Sie herausgefunden, der hat ein Vitamin-B12-Mangel.
Wie nennt man dann diese Erkrankungsform oder diese Anämieform dann auch noch?
Eine hyperkrome megaloblastere Anämie.
Und wenn das mit Vitamin-B12-Assoziiertes verbunden ist,
dann ist das eine sogenannte perniziosa.
Perniziosa.
Perniziosa Anämie, sagt auch der Deutsch.
Wenn Sie Vitamin-B12-Mangel nachgewiesen haben,
können Sie auch eine perniziosa Diagnostizie.
Aber jetzt müssen Sie gucken, warum hat dieser Mensch zu wenig Vitamin-B12?
Wie gehen Sie dann vor? Was ist der nächste Schritt?
Ursache, Autographie, Endoscopy.
Gastroskopie, ja.
Wer hat etwas gesagt?
Noch mal?
Gastroskopie.
Sehr gut.
Was sehen wir in der Gastroskopie?
Steinbaut von Magen.
Atrophie.
Atrophie, genau so ist es.
Sehr gut.
Und was muss der Gastroenterologe oder der Endoscopiker machen?
Auf jeden Fall?
Hyopstien.
Hyopstien muss er abnehmen.
Und der Atrophie muss dann gucken, ob eine Atrophie der Schleimhaut da ist.
Ist nämlich eine Schleimhaut-Atrophie da?
Dann kann diese Schleimhaut keinen Intrinsic-Faktor bilden.
Und dann kann im Juni, im Terminalen Ilium, besser gesagt,
kein Vitamin-B12 aufgenommen werden.
Ja?
Warum dieser Mensch jetzt eine Schleimhaut-Atrophie hat,
kann ich nicht sagen.
Aber jetzt komme ich zu dem, was Mahmoud Dujer vorhin gesagt hat.
Der hat keinen Burnout, der hat einfach einen Stressmagen.
Wer 12 Stunden, 14 Stunden auf der Baustelle verbringt,
wer so eine Verantwortung hat, der hat immer einen Stressmagen.
Man hat sich nicht stressig, ihr Stress.
Das hat der einfach nicht so bemerkt.
Es gibt manche Menschen, die sind sehr empfindlich
und die Menschen sind sehr widerstandsfähig, die merken das einfach nicht.
Bis dann irgendwelche Probleme da sind.
Jetzt haben Sie mit der Magenspiegelung, mit der Biobsie,
eine Schleimhaut-Atrophie nachgewiesen.
Und jetzt können Sie einfach den Mechanismus gut wiedergeben.
Das ist einfach ein, durch die Magenschleimhaut-Atrophie entstandene
Intrinsic-Faktor-Mangel mit, ich sage mal, abnehmen,
Vitamin B12-Resort-Option und dadurch entstanden eine Perniziosa,
eine hyperkome megaloblastere Anämie.
Und was ist jetzt Ihre Therapie?
Vitamin B12 und Foligest.
Bitte nochmal.
Ich möchte erstmal eine,
eine Satz verbinden, bitte.
Ich würde gerne.
Ja, ja, da hemoglobin unter 7 ist, würde ich ganz zuerst,
vielleicht Bluttransfusion.
Wollt man das so bedenkt?
Blut, ich denke, ist wichtig.
Also ich würde diesen Menschen kein Blut geben.
Dem geht es ja gut.
Der hat nur unter Belastung bis zu Dyspne.
Aber ich würde dem jetzt kein Blut geben.
Warum?
Weil ich weiß, wenn ich dem Vitamin B12 und Folsage gebe,
wird sich dein Labor relativ schnell normalisieren.
Warum ihn mit fremdem Blut in Gefahr bringen?
Ich habe so gedacht, dass hemoglobin unter 7 ist.
Ja, das ist nicht für jedermann gültig.
Und man muss immer die Überzeugung haben,
fremdes Blut stellt immer eine Gefahr dar.
Und wenn jemand nicht akut, lebensbedrohlich geblutet hat
oder aber irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen wie Herzprobleme
oder irgendwelche Gefäßprobleme hat mit AVK oder ähnliches,
wo dann eine Ischemia, eine kritische Ischemia drohen kann,
dann würde ich den HB von 4, 5 bei normalen Menschen tolerieren.
Vor allem, wenn durch meine Maßnahmen
der HB-Wert relativ steil ansteigen wird.
Also keine E-Cas geben, definitiv nicht.
Aber Sie müssen sofort, und zwar ohne Zeitverzug,
mit Vitamin B12 und mit Folsage sofort beginnen.
Und wie geben Sie denn Vitamin B12?
Intramuskulär kann man verabrechen.
Welche Form von Vitamin B12 nehmen Sie da?
Welche Form?
Den Begriff Vitamin B12 kennt nicht jeder, sag ich mal.
Da muss man auch den anderen Begriff kennen.
Transcobalamin.
Wie geben Sie das normal? Können Sie es wiederholen?
Wie gibt man das nochmal? Sie hatten es richtig gesagt?
Intramuskulär.
Wie können Sie es auch noch geben? Müssen Sie das intramuskulär geben?
Ja, wir können auch per Oral verabrechen, aber das hilft nicht.
Das hilft nicht, das ist nämlich der Fehler.
Der Mensch produziert, der kann den Trinsigfaktor.
Das dürfen Sie nicht oral geben. Was können Sie noch machen?
Intravenös geben.
Ich würde so einem Menschen sofort eine Ampulle Transcobalamin
intravenös geben und die zweite Ampulle würde ich im geben,
weil das wird langsamer über den Muskel aufgenommen.
Aber der hat einen absoluten Mangel, der braucht Substrat,
der braucht das Vitamin, damit die Blutbildung im Knochenmark
vernünftig anlaufen kann.
Wie viele Tage muss man verabrechen, diese Transcobalamin?
Bis das Ganze besser wird.
Dass Sie sehen können, dass der HB ansteigt, 3 bis 5 Tage.
Das geht ganz schnell.
Bei der Perniziosa haben Sie den Vorteil,
dass Sie durch Vitaminsubstitution einen raschen Anstieg,
einen rasches Ansprechen erkennen können.
Sie sehen das, woran sehen Sie, ob das Blut anspricht
oder nicht, nicht an dem HB, sondern an dem abnehmenden LDH.
Die LDH geht zurück.
Was wird auch noch besser?
Was steigt im Gegenzug, wenn LDH abfällt?
Was hatten Sie gefragt, Marmut Holger?
Reticulosit.
Ja, die Reticulozitten steigen sogar.
Und zwar sehr stark, so dass man auch von einer Reticulozitten-Krise
spricht manchmal.
Dann hat man nicht, was ich vorhin gesagt habe,
Reticulozitten von 6, ich habe auch Reticulozitten von 250,
270 gesehen.
Direkt nach Vitamin B12-Gabe.
Das pusht im Knochenmark die Blutbildungen.
Und wie müssen wir die Vollsäure geben?
Also auch da kann man die erste Ampule in Travénus geben.
Aber es reicht auch, wenn man zum Beispiel 5 Milligramm Tablette
voll sahen, 5 Milligramm, erst mal jeden Tag die nächsten 4-6 Wochen.
Bis ein normales, ein normales Vollsäure-Spiegel nachweisbar ist.
Ja?
Und Vitamin B12 muss man dann wahrscheinlich in den ersten 4-6 Wochen
öfters geben, einmal die Woche, 4 Mal, dann einmal im Monat
und dann einmal alle 3 Monate, bis seine Depots aufgefüllt sind.
Und dann dürfte sich sein Blutbild völlig normalisiert haben.
Ja?
Und sie kontrolliert sich, dass man die Blutbildungen
von einem Blutbild völlig normalisiert haben.
Ja?
Und sie kontrollieren am Anfang jeden Tag Blutbild,
die Rettikolozyten und die LDH.
Und warum kommt es aber zu dieser Hemmolüse?
Oder ich frage mal andersrum,
nur damit ihr das dann auch mal irgendwo registriert habt.
Wo findet denn diese Hemmolüse statt?
Im Splen, im Milz.
Nein?
Im Knochenmark.
Richtig, das ist nämlich der große Unterschied.
Es ist keine intravasale Hemmolüse.
Es ist keine splenische Hemmolüse.
Ja.
Das ist eine Knochenmark-Hemmolüse.
Warum?
Weil die DNA in den Zellen vitamin B12 abhängig arbeitet.
Die RNA dafür aber nicht.
Die DNA reift nicht aus.
Und die Zellen sterben früher ab.
Aber dadurch, dass die RNA ohne Vitamin B12 verarbeitet,
wird das Zytoplasma größer.
Es entsteht ein Ungleichgewicht.
Ein Ungleichgewicht zwischen Kern und Plasma.
Die Zellenriese sind riesengroß,
aber sie sind nicht überlebensfähig.
Hier reift eine Zelle, desto kleiner wird sie.
Ein Erritroblast ist so groß, ein Erritroziert ist so klein.
Und in der Reife wird er immer kleiner, kleiner, kleiner.
Und dann schmeißt er seinen Kern raus.
Und am Ende hat man einen Erritroziert.
Aber wenn der Erritroblast krank ist,
weil seine DNA nicht funktioniert,
dann wird die zerstört.
Und am Ende kommt nichts an.
Deswegen haben wir auch keine Rettikolozyten.
Wenn ich aber Vitamin B12 gebe,
dann reifen die plötzlich mehr und mehr aus,
dann entstehen auch viele, viele Rettikolozyten.
Und das sieht man dann im peripheren Blut,
als Rettikolozytenkrise.
Nach der Therapie besteht ein Rettikolozytkrise, oder?
Ja, direkt nach Beginn der Therapie.
Vitamin B12 und Vorsäure, wenn Sie das geben.
Ist das gefällig?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Sie sehen einfach nur, ob sein Knochenmark
auf die Vitamine anspricht oder nicht.
Ob er jetzt regeneriert oder nicht, sagt man.
Und das ist meistens immer der Fall.
Und das können Sie daran messen.
Also bei der Perniziosa oder megaloblastären Anämie
haben Sie einige Parameter, die Sie jeden Tag kontrollieren.
Rettikolozyten, LDH, Haptoglobin, Bilirubin und Hämoglobin.